[Laughter]
come to order and the first order of
business is to try to cool the room down
so we'll see if we can do that but the
Attorney General will be testifying here
in a bit about the Muller report now I
want to thank him for coming to the
committee and giving us an explanation
as to the actions he took and why he
took them regarding the Muller report
and here's the good news and here's the
Muller report you can read it for
yourself that's about four hundred and
something pages I can't say I've read at
all but I've read most of it there's an
unredacted version over in the
classified section of the Senate a room
where you can go look at the unwrapped
redacted version and I did that and I
found it not to change anything in terms
of an outcome but a bit about the Muller
report who is Muller for those who may
not know I don't know where you've been
but you may not know the Bob Muller has
a reputation in this town and throughout
the country as being an outstanding
lawyer and a man of the law it was the
FBI director he was the deputy attorney
general he was in charge of the Criminal
Division at the Department of Justice he
was a United States Marine and he has
served his country in a variety of
circumstances long and well for those
who took time to read the report I think
it was well-written
very thorough and let me tell you what
went into this report there were 19
lawyers employed approximately 40 FBI
agents Intel analysts forensic forensic
accountants and other staff 2,800
subpoenas
dude 500 witnesses interviewed 500
search warrants executed more than 230
orders for communication records so they
records could be obtained 13 requests to
foreign governments for evidence over 25
million dollars spent over 2 years we
may not agree on much but I hope we can
agree that he had ample resources took a
lot of time and talked to a lot of
people and you can read for yourself
what he found the Attorney General will
tell us a bit about what his opinion of
the report is in terms of interacting
with the White House the White House
turned over to mr. Muller 1.4 million
documents and records never asserted
executive privilege one time over 20
White House staffers including eight
from the White House counsel's office
were interviewed voluntarily Don Magan
chief counsel for the White House was
interviewed for over 30 hours everybody
that they wanted to talk to from the
Trump campaign on the ground they were
able to talk to the president submitted
himself to written interrogatories so to
the American people mr. Muller was the
right guy to do this job I always
believed that attorney General Sessions
was conflicted out because he was part
of the campaign he was the right guy
with ample resources and the cooperation
he needed to find out what happened was
given in my view but there were two
campaigns in 2016 and we'll talk about
the second one in a minute so what have
we learned from this report after all
this time and all this money
mr. Muller and his team concluded there
was no collusion I didn't know like many
of you here on the Republican side we
all agreed that mr. Muller should be
allowed to do his job without
interference I joined with some
colleagues on the other side to
introduce legislation to protect the
special counsel they could only be
removed for cause he was never removed
he was allowed to do his job
so no collusion no coordination no
conspiracy between the Trump campaign
and the Russian government regarding the
2016 election as to obstruction of
justice mr. Muller left it to mr. Barr
to decide after two years and all this
time he said mr. Barr you decide mr.
Barr did they're a bunch of lawyers on
this committee and I will tell you the
following you have to have specific
intent to obstruct justice
if there's no underlying crime pretty
hard to figure out what intent might be
if there was never a crime to begin with
the president never did anything to stop
Muller from doing his job
so I guess the theory goes now we don't
okay he didn't collude with the Russians
and he didn't specifically do anything
to stop Muller
but attempted obstruction justice of a
crime it never occurred I guess is sort
of the new standard around here we'll
see if that makes any sense
to me it doesn't now there's another
campaign it was the Clinton campaign
what have we learned from this report
the Russians interfered in our election
so can some bipartisanship come out of
this I hope so
I intend to work my colleagues on the
other side to introduce the deter Act
and to introduce legislation to defend
the integrity of the voting system
Senator Durbin and I have legislation
that would deny anyone admittance into
the United States
a visa through the immigration system
that they were involved in interfering
in an American election working with
Senator Whitehouse and Blumenthal to
make sure that if you hack into a state
election system even though it's not
tied to their internet that's a crime I
would like to do more to harden our
infrastructure because the Russians did
it it wasn't some 400-pound guy sitting
on a bed somewhere it was the Russians
and they're still doing it and it could
be the Chinese it could be somebody next
so my takeaway from this report is that
we've got a lot of work to do to defend
democracy against the Russians and other
bad actors and I promised the committee
we'll get on with that work hopefully in
a bipartisan fashion the other campaign
the other campaign was investigated not
by mr. Muller by people within the
Department of Justice the accusation
against the Clinton Secretary Clinton
was that she said a private server up
somewhere in her house and classified
information was on it to avoid the
disclosure requirements and the
transparency requirements required to be
in Secretary of State so that was
investigated what do we know we know
that the person in charge of
investigating hated Trump's guts
I don't know how Mr Muller felt about
Trump but I don't think anybody on our
side believes they'd had a personal
animosity toward the president at the
point he couldn't do his job this is
what struck said on fair both at 12:00
2016 now he's in charge of the Clinton
email investigation
oh he's Trump's abysmal I keep hoping
the charade will end and people will
just dump him February 12 2016 page is
the Department of Justice lawyer
assigned to this case March 3rd 2016 god
trump is a loathsome human being struck
oh my god Trump's an idiot Paige he's
awful struck God Hillary should win 100
million to nothing compare those two
people to Muller March 16 2016
I cannot believe Trump is likely to be
an actual serious candidate for
president July the 21st 2016 Trump is a
disaster have no idea how destabilizing
his presidency would be August the 8th
2016 3 days before struck was made
deputy acting in charge of the
counterintelligence division of the FBI
he's never going to become president
right page destruct no no he won't
we'll stop him these are the people
investigating the Clinton email
situation and start the
counterintelligence investigation of the
Trump campaign compare them to moer
August the 15th 2016 struck I want to
believe the path you threw out for
consideration and Andy's office that
there's no way he gets elected but I'm
afraid we can't take that risk it's like
an insurance policy in the unlikely
event you die before you're 40 August 26
2016 just went to the Southern Virginia
Walmart I could smell the Trump support
October the 19th 2016 Trump is a [ __ ]
idiot he's unable to provide a coherent
answer sorry to the kids out there these
are the people that made a decision the
Clinton didn't do anything wrong and a
counterintelligence investigation the
Trump campaign was warranted we're going
to end a bipartisan way I hope deal with
Russia but when the Muller report is put
to bed in it soon will be this committee
is gonna look long and hard and how this
all started
we're gonna look at the FISA warrant
process did Russia provide Christopher
steal the information about Trump that
turned out to be garbage that was used
to get a warrant on an American system
citizen and if so how did the system
fail was there real effort between
Papadopoulos and anybody in Russia to
use the Clinton emails stolen but stole
by the Russians or was that thought
planted in his mind I don't know but
we're going to look and I can tell you
this if you change the names y'all want
to look to everything I just said just
substitute Clinton for Trump see what
all these people were cameras would be
seeing out here about this as to
cooperation in the Clinton investigation
I told you what the Trump people did
tell me a little bit about what the
Clinton people did there was a
protective order for the server issued
by the house and there was a request by
the State Department to preserve all the
information on the server
Paul Kim betta after having the
protective order used a software program
called bleach bit to wipe this email
server clean has anybody ever heard of
Paul Kim betta know under a protective
order from the house to preserve the
information under a request from the
State Department to preserve the
information on the server
he used a bleach fit program to wipe it
clean what happened to him nothing 18
devices possessed by Secretary Clinton
she used to do business as Secretary how
many of them were turned over to the FBI
none two of them couldn't be turned over
because Judith caspere took
hammer and destroyed two of them what
happened to her
nothing so the bottom line is we're
about to hear from mr. Barr the results
of a two-year investigation into the
Trump campaign all things Russia the
actions the president took before and
after the campaign 25 million dollars 40
FBI agents I appreciate very much what
mr. Muller did for the country I have
read most of the report for me it is
over senator Feinstein
Thank You mr. chairman and welcome
Attorney General on March 24th you sent
a letter to chairman Graham and the
ranking member of this committee
providing your summary of the principal
conclusion set out in Special Counsel
Muller's report this letter was widely
reported as a win for the president and
was characterized as confirming there
was no conclusion following this letter
the White House put out a statement
declaring the special counsel and I
quote the special counsel did not find
any collusion and did not find any
obstruction end quote and that the
report quote was a total and complete
exoneration end quote of the president
however last night the Washington Post
reported that special counsel Muller
sent you a letter in late March where he
said your letter to Congress failed to
quote fully captured the context nature
and substance of his office's work and
conclusions and quote and that he spoke
with you about the concern that the
letter threatened to undermine the
public confidence in the outcome of the
investigations that's in quotes as well
then on April 18th you held a press
conference where you announced
repeatedly that the Muller report found
no collusion and no evidence of a crime
an hour later a redacted copy of the
Muller report was provided to the public
and the Congress and we saw why Muller
was concerned contrary to the
declarations of the total and complete
exoneration the special counsels report
contains substantial evidence of
misconduct first Special Counsel
Muller's report confirms that the
Russian government implemented a social
media campaign to mislead millions of
Americans and that Russian intelligence
services
into the DNC and the d-triple-c
computers stole emails and memos and
systematically release them to impact
the presidential election your March
letter stated that there was no evidence
that the Trump campaign quote conspired
or coordinated with Russia end quote
however the report outlined substantial
evidence that the Trump campaign
welcomed encouraged and expected to
benefit electorally
from Russia's interference in the
election the Muller report also details
how time and time again
the Trump campaign took steps to gain
advantage from Russia's unlawful
interference for example President
Trump's campaign manager Paul Manafort
passed internal campaign polling data
messaging and strategy updates to
Constantine kill limit column mnek a
Russian national
with ties to Russian intelligence the
Muller report explains how Paul Manafort
brief clinic in early August of 2016 on
and a quote the state of the Trump
campaign and mana forts plan to win the
election and quote including the
campaign's focus on the battleground
states of Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and Minnesota
next the Muller report documents the
Trump campaigns communications regarding
secretary Clinton's and the DNC s stolen
emails specifically the report states
and I quote within approximately five
hours a president Trump calling on
Russia to find secretary Clinton's
emails Russian intelligence agency GRU
officers quote targeted for the first
time Clinton's personal office end quote
the Muller report also reveals that
President
Trump repeatedly asked individuals
affiliated with his campaign including
Michael Flynn quote to find the deleted
Clinton emails and quote these efforts
included suggestions to contact foreign
intelligence services Russian hackers
and individuals on the dark web the
report confirms the Trump knew of
WikiLeaks releases of the stolen emails
and receives status about status updates
about upcoming releases while his
campaign promoted coverage of the leaks
Donald Trump jr. communicated directly
with WikiLeaks and at its request
publicly tweeted a link to emails stolen
from Clinton's campaign manager second
in your March letter to Congress you
concluded and I quote that the evidence
is not sufficient to establish that the
president committed an obstruction of
justice offense end quote
however special counsel Muller
methodically outlines 10 episodes some
continuing multiple actions by the
President to mislead the American people
and interfere with the investigations
into Russian interference and
obstruction in one example the president
repeatedly called White House Counsel
Don Magan at home and directed him to
fire Muller saying quote Muller has to
go call me back when you do it then
later the president repeatedly ordered
Magan to release a press statement and
write a letter saying the president did
not order McMullen fired the Muller
report also outlines efforts by
President Trump to influence witness
testimony and deter cooperation with law
enforcement for example the president's
team communicated to witnesses
that pardons would be available if they
quote stayed on message and quote and
remained quote on the team end quote
in one case the president sent messages
through his personal lawyers to Paul
Manafort that he would be taken care of
and just quote sit tight and quote the
president then publicly affirmed this
communication by staying stating that
Manafort was quote a brave man and quote
for refusing to break
similarly the Muller report stated the
president used inducements in the form
of positive messages in an effort to get
Michael Cohen not to cooperate and then
turn to attacks and intimidation to
deter the provision of information or
undermine Cohen's credibility finally
while the March letter to Congress and
the April press conference left the
impression there were no remaining
questions to examine this report notes
several limitations Muller faced while
gathering the facts that Congress needed
to examine more than once the report
documents that legal condition scuse me
conclusions were not drawn because
witnesses refused to answer questions or
failed to recall the events in addition
numerous witnesses including but not
limited to Jared Kushner Sarah Sanders
Rudolph Giuliani Michael Flynn Steve
Bannon and John Kelly all stated they
could not recall events the President
himself said more than 30 times that he
could not recall or remember enough to
be able to answer written questions from
the special counsel the special counsel
also recounted that quote some
associated with the Trump campaign
deleted relevant communicate
Asians or communicated during the
relevant period using applications that
featured encryption or do not provide
for long term retention of data and
quote based on these gaps the Muller
report concluded and I quote again the
office cannot rule out the possibility
that the unavailable information would
have shed additional light on or cast a
new light on events described in the
report end quote and contrary to the
conclusion that the special counsels
report did not find evidence of
communication or coordination between
the Trump campaign and Russia the Muller
report explicitly states and I quote a
statement that the investigation did not
establish particular facts does not mean
there was no evidence of those facts
volume 2 page 2 let me conclude with
this Congress has both the
constitutional duty and the authority to
investigate the serious findings
contained in the Muller report I
strongly believe that this committee
needs to hear directly from special
counsel Muller about his views on the
report in his March letter I also
believe senators should have the
opportunity to ask him about these
subjects in questions directly I have
requested this to our Chairman to
authorize a hearing with special counsel
Muller and I hope that will happen soon
Thank You mr. chairman thank you before
we receive your testimony mr. Barr we
have the letter that mr. Miller sent to
you on March 27th 2019 I'll put that in
the record now the floor is yours
what what gotta swear you in sorry
Ptolemy you can solemnly swear the
testimony about to give this committee
is the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
except you God yes sorry about that
Thank You mr. chairman and ranking
member Feinstein members of the
committee during my confirmation process
there were two concerns that dominated
as I think you will all agree the first
was whether I would in any way impede or
curtail special counsels molars
investigation and the second whether I
would make public his final report as
you see Bob Muller was allowed to to
complete his work as he saw fit and as
to the report even though the applicable
regulations require that the report is
to be made to the AG and is to remain
confidential and not be made public I
told this committee that I intended to
exercise whatever discretion I had to
make as much of the report available to
the public into congressional leaders as
I could consistent with the law this has
been done I arrived at the department on
February 14th and shortly thereafter I
asked it to be communicated to Bob
Miller's team that in preparing the
report we requested that they make it so
we could readily identify sexy material
so we could quickly process the report
did you tell the public what 60s sixties
grand jury material that cannot be made
public it's prohibited by statute and I
wanted that identified so we could
redact that material and prepare the
report for public release as quickly as
we could when I arrived at the
department I found and was eventually
briefed in on the investigation I found
that the Deputy Attorney General and his
principal associate deputy at
O'Callahan were in regular discussions
with the counsel's office had been and
they communicated this request and had
discussions about that both the timing
of the report and the nature of the
report on March 5th
I met with Bob at the suggestion of the
deputy and the principal associate
deputy Bob Muller
to get a readout on what his conclusions
would be on March 25th and at that
meeting I asked I reiterated to a
special counsel Muller that in order to
to have the shortest possible time
before I was in a position to release
the report I asked that they identify
sexy material when I received the report
on March 22nd and we were hoping to to
have that easily identified the 6e
material unfortunately it did not come
in that form and it quickly became
apparent that it would take about three
or four weeks to identify that material
and other material that had to be
redacted so there was necessarily going
to be a gap between the receipt of the
report and getting the full report out
publicly the deputy and I identified
four categories of information that we
believe required redaction and I think
you will all know of them but they were
the grand jury material the 6e material
information that the intelligence
community advised would reveal sensitive
sources and methods information that if
revealed at this stage would impinge on
the investigation or prosecution of
related cases and information that would
unfairly affect the privacy and
reputational interests of peripheral
third parties we want about redacting
this material in concert with the
special counsels office we needed their
assistance to identify
the 6e material in particular the
redactions were all carried out by DOJ
lawyers with special counsel lawyers in
consultation with intelligence community
the report contained a substantial
amount of material over which the
president could have asserted executive
privilege but the president made the
decision not to assert executive
privilege and to make public as much of
the report as we could subject to the
redactions that we feel required now as
you see the report has been lightly
redacted the public version has been
estimated to have only 10% redactions
almost the vast bulk of those word
actions relate to are in volume 1 which
is the volume that deals with collusion
and it relates to existing ongoing cases
volume 2 has only about 2% redactions
for the public version so 98% of volume
to dealing with obstruction is available
to the public we have made a version of
the report available to congressional
leaders that only contains word actions
of grand jury material for this version
overall redactions are less than 2
percent for the whole report and for
volume to dealing with obstruction they
are less than 1/10 of 1% so given the
limited nature of redactions I believe
that the public publicly released report
will allow every American to understand
the results of the special counsels
work
by now everyone is familiar with the
special counsels bottom line conclusions
about the Russian attempts to interfere
in the election in volume one the
special council found that the Russians
in cage engaged in two distinct schemes
first the internet research agency a
Russian entity with close ties to the
Russian government conducted a
disinformation and social media
operation to sow discord among Americans
second the GRU Russian military
intelligence hacked into computers and
stole emails from individuals affiliated
with the Democratic Party and Hillary
Clinton's campaign the Special Counsel
investigated whether anyone affiliated
with President Trump's campaign
conspired or coordinated with these
criminal schemes they concluded that
they there was not sufficient evidence
to establish that there had been any
conspiracy or coordination with the
Russian government or the IRA as you
know volume 2 of his report dealt with
obstruction and the special council
considered whether certain actions of
the president could amount to
obstruction he decided not to reach a
conclusion
instead the report recounts 10 episodes
and discusses potential legal theories
for connecting the president's actions
to elements of obstruction offenses now
we first heard that the special counsels
decision not to decide the obstruction
issue at a meet at the March 5th meeting
when he came over to the department and
we were frankly surprised that that they
were not going to reach a decision on
obstruction and we asked them a lot
about the reasoning behind this and the
basis for this special counsel Muller
stated three times to us in that meeting
in response to our questioning that he
emphatically was not saying that but for
the OLC opinion he would have found
obstruction he said that in the future
the facts of a case against a president
might be such that a special counsel
would recommend abandoning
ILC opinion but this is not such a case
we did not understand exactly why the
special counsel was not reaching the a
decision and when we pressed him on it
he said that his team was still
formulating the explanation once we
heard that the special counsel was not
reaching a conclusion on obstruction the
deputy and I discussed and agreed that
the department had to reach a decision
we had the responsibility to assess the
evidence as set forth in the report and
to make the judgment I say this because
the special counsel was appointed to
carry out the investigative and
prosecutorial functions of the
department and to do it as part of the
Department of Justice the powers he was
using including the power of using a
grand jury and using compulsory process
exists for that purpose the function of
the Department of Justice in this arena
which is to determine whether or not
there has been criminal conduct it's a
binary decision is there enough evidence
to show a crime and do we believe a
crime has been committed
we don't conduct criminal investigations
just to collect information and put it
out to the public we do so to make a
decision and here we thought there was
an additional reason which is this was a
very public investigation and we had
made clear that the results of the
investigation were going to be made
public and the deputy and I felt that
the evidence developed by the special
counsel was not sufficient to establish
that the president committed a crime and
therefore it would be irresponsible and
unfair for the department to release a
report without stating the department's
conclusions and thus leave it hanging as
to whether the department considered
that there had been criminal conduct
so the Deputy Attorney General and I
conducted a careful review of the report
with our staffs and legal advisors and
while we disagreed with some of the
legal theories and felt that many of the
episodes discussed in the report would
not constitute obstruction as a matter
of law we didn't rest our decision on
that we took each of the ten
episodes and we assess them against the
analytical framework that had been set
forth by the special counsel and we
concluded that the evidence developed
during the special counsels
investigation was not sufficient to
establish that the president committed
an obstruction of justice offense let me
just talk a little bit about this March
24th letter and and Bob Miller's letter
I think on the 20 which I received on
the 28th when the report came in on the
22nd and we saw it was going to take a
great deal of time to get it out to the
public
I made the determination that we had to
put out some information about the
bottom line
the body politic was in a high state of
agitation there was massive interest in
learning what the bottom line results of
Bob Miller's investigation was
particularly as the collusion former
government officials were confident
confidently predicting that the
president and members of his family were
going to be indicted there were people
suggesting that if it took any time to
turn around the report and get it out it
would mean that the president was in
legal jeopardy
so I didn't feel that it was in the
public interest
to allow this to go on for several weeks
without saying anything and so I decided
to simply state what the bottom line
conclusions were which is what the
department normally does make it binary
determination is there a crime or isn't
there a crime we prepared the letter for
that purpose to state the bottom line
conclusions we use the language from the
report to state those bottom line
conclusions i analogize it to announcing
after an extended trial with the verdict
of the trial is pending release of the
full transcript that's what we were
trying to do notify the people as to the
bottom line conclusion we were not
trying to summarize the four hundred and
ten page report
so we released that I offered Bob mother
the opportunity to review that letter
before it went out and he declined on
Thursday morning I received it probably
was received at the department Wednesday
night or evening but on Thursday morning
I received a letter from Bob the letter
that's just been put into the record and
I called Bob and said you know what's
the issue here are you suggesting if he
was suggesting that the March 24th
letter was inaccurate and he said no but
that the press reporting had been
inaccurate and that the press was
reading too much into it and I asked him
you know specifically what his concern
was and he said that his concern focused
on his explanation of why he did not
reach a conclusion on obstruction and he
wanted more put out on that issue he
wanted he argued for putting out
summaries of each volume the executive
summaries that had been written by his
office and if not that and other
material that focused on the issue of
why he didn't reach the obstruction
question but he was very clear with me
that he was not suggesting that we had
misrepresented his report I told Bob
that I was not interested in putting out
summaries and I wasn't gonna put out the
report piecemeal I wanted to get the
whole report out and I thought summaries
by very definition regardless of who
prepared them would be under-inclusive
and we'd have sort of a series of
different debates and public discord
over each tranche of information that
went out and I wanted to get everything
out at once and we should start working
our pact
and so the following day I put out a
letter explaining
the process we were following and
stressing that the March 24th letter was
not a summary of the report but a
statement of the principal conclusions
and that people would be able to see Bob
Miller's entire thinking when the report
was made public so I'll end my statement
there mr. chairman and glad to take any
questions thank you very much
as to the actual report itself was there
ever an occasion where you wanted to
something was redacted from the report
that mr. Muller objected to I wouldn't
say objected to my understanding is the
categories were defined by me and the
deputy I don't think that I have no I
don't believe work with him to redact
the right those categories were executed
by DOJ lawyers working with his lawyers
I think there were maybe a few judgment
calls very few as to whether or not
something as a Prudential matter should
be treated as a reputational interest or
something so there may have been some
occasions of that but but as as far as I
understand it you did not want to hurt
somebody's reputation unless it really
affected the outcome is that correct
so was there any disagreement about 6e
material not that I'm aware of
any disagreement about classified
information not that I'm aware of
okay so um the conclusions in your phase
four page summary you think accurately
reflect his bottom line on collision is
that correct yes and you can read it for
yourself if you got any doubt as to
obstruction of justice
were you surprised he was gonna let you
decide yes I was surprised I I think the
very perfunctory you dove investigative
and prosecuted is performed for the
purpose of people that you actually
indict you know
I can't remember off the top of my head
it was a lot yeah so he actually has the
ability and died if he wants to he's
used that power during the
investigations that correct that's
correct and the other thing that was
confusing to me is that the
investigation carried on for a while as
additional episodes were were looked
into episodes involving the President
and so my question is or was why were
those investigated if at the end of the
day you weren't gonna reach a decision
on them so did you consult Deputy
Attorney General Rosenstein about the
obstruction matter constantly yeah so
was he an agreement with your decision
not to proceed forward yes sorry the
agreement what not not to proceed
forward right obstruction right okay so
very quickly give us your reasoning why
you think it would be inappropriate to
proceed forward on obstruction of
justice in this case well generally
speaking an obstruction case typically
has two aspects to it one there's
usually an underlying criminality that
lets stop right there yeah was there an
underlying crime here no so usually
there is usually but it's not it's not
necessary but the typical case sort of
the paradigm attic case is there's an
underlying crime and then the person
implicated or people implicate are
concerned about that criminality being
discovered take an inherently malignant
act as the Supreme Court said to to
obstruct that investigation so these
growing documents what people were
worried about that he fired call me to
stop the Russian investigation that's
one of the concerns people had let me
tell you a little bit about Comey
I do not have confidence in him coming
any longer that was Chuck Schumer
November the 2nd 2016 I think he Comey
should take a hard look at what he has
done and I think it would not be
a bad thing for the American people if
he did step down Bernie Sanders January
the 15th 2017
the president ought to fire Comey
immediately and he ought to initiate an
investigation that is congressman Nadler
November the 14th 2016 did you have a
problem of the way call me handled the
Clinton email investigation yes I said
so at the time okay so and given the
fact that a lot of people come he should
be fired did you find that to be a
persuasive act of obstructing justice no
I think even the report at the end of
the day came to the conclusion if you if
you read the analysis that a reason that
loomed large therefore his termination
was his refusal to tell the public what
he was privately telling the president
which was that the president was not
under investigation as to where we go
forward as as to how we go forward would
you recommend that this committee and
every other committee of Congress do our
best to harden our infrastructure
against the future Russian attacks
absolutely yeah you think Russia is
still up to it
yes do you think other countries may get
involved in our elections in thorny Tony
yes so you would support an effort by
Congress working with administration to
harden our electoral infrastructure yes
is that one that takeaways of the Moller
report yes do you share my concerns
about the FISA warrant process yes
do you share my concerns about the
counterintelligence investigation how
was opened and why it was opened yes you
share my concerns that the professional
lack of professionalism in the Clinton
email investigations something we should
all look at yes do you expect to change
your mind about the bottom line
conclusions of the Moller report no do
you know bob muller yes do you trust him
yes how long have you known him 30 years
roughly
you think he at the time he needed yes
you think he had the money he needed yes
you think he had the resources needed
yes
you think he did a thorough job yes and
I think he feels he did a thorough job
and and and had adequate evidence to
make the calls do you think the
president's campaign in 2016 was
thoroughly looked at in terms of whether
or not they colluded with the Russians
yes and the answer is no according to
Bob Muller that's right he couldn't
decide about obstruction you did is that
correct that's right you feel good about
your decision absolutely thank you very
much chairman mr. Attorney General the
special counsels report describes how
the president directed White House
Counsel Don McGann to fire special
counsel Muller and later told him again
to write a letter quote for our records
and quote stating that the president had
not ordered him to fire Muller
the report also recounts how the
president made repeated efforts to get
McGann to change his story
knowing that McGann believed the
president's version of events was false
the special counsel found and I quote
substantial evidence and quote that the
president tried to change McGann's
account in order to prevent further
scrutiny of the president towards the
investigation special counsel also found
that McGann is a credible witness with
no motive to lie or exaggerate given the
position he held in the White House
here's the question does existing law
prohibit efforts to get a witness to lie
to say something the witness believes is
false yes and lie to the government yes
and and what law is that obstruction
statutes the obstructions statute and
you don't have it I guess before you I'm
not sure which one they were referring
to here is
was probably 15 12 C - so these things
in effect constitute obstruction well
you're talking in general terms you're
not talking what I'm talking about
specifically yes you're correct in a
sense that substantially the special
counsel in his report found substantial
evidence that the president tried to
change McGann's account in order to
prevent and this is a quote further
scrutiny of the president toward the
investigation and quote the special
counsel also found McGann is a credible
witness with no motive to lie or
exaggerate so what I'm asking you then
is that a credible charged under the
obstruction statute we felt that we felt
at that episode the government would not
be able to establish obstruction the if
you go back and you if you look at the
the episode where McGann the president
gave McGann an obstruction in an
instruction McGann's version of that is
quite clear and each time he gave it
which is that the instruction said go to
Rosenstein raise the issue of conflict
of interest and muller has to go because
of this conflict of interest so there's
no question that that that the whatever
instruction was giving McGann had to do
with conflict of it motors conflict of
interest now the president later said
that what he meant was that the conflict
of interest should be raised with
Rosenstein but the decision should be
left with Rose ensign on the other end
of the spectrum
it appears that McGann felt it was more
directive and that the president was
essentially saying push Rosen Stein to
invoke a conflict of interest to push
Muller out
wherever it fell on that spectrum of
interest the New York Times story was
very different the New York Times story
said flat out that the president
directed the firing of Muller he told
him again fire Muller now that there's
something very different between firing
a special counsel outright which
suggests ending the investigation and
having a special counsel removed for
conflict which suggests that you're
going to have another special counsel so
the fact is that even under McGann's and
and then as the report says and
recognizes there is evidence the
president truly felt that The Times
article was inaccurate and he wanted
McGann to correct it so we believe that
it would be impossible for the
government to establish beyond a
reasonable doubt that the president
understood that he that he was
instructing m'g and to say something
false because it wasn't necessarily
false
moreover McGann had weeks before already
given testimony to the to the special
counsel and the president was aware of
that and as the report indicates it
could also have been the case that what
he wanted that he wasn't primarily
concerned about Press reports and making
it clear that he never outright directed
the firing of Muller so in turn so in
terms of the request to ask McGann to
memorialize that fact we do not think in
this case that the government could show
corrupt intent beyond a reasonable doubt
just to finish this but you still have a
situation where a president essentially
tries to change the lawyers account in
order to prevent further criticism of
himself well that's not a crime so you
in this situation instruct someone to
lie no it has to be well to be
obstruction of justice the lie has to be
tied to impairing the evidence in a
particular proceeding McGann had already
given his evidence and I think I think
it would be plausible that the purpose
of McGann memorializing what the
president was asking was to make the
record that the president never directed
him to fire and there is a distinction
between saying to someone go fire him go
fire Muller and saying have him removed
based on conflict and what would have
different results what would that
conflict be well the difference between
them is if you remove someone for a
conflict of interest then there'd be
another presumably another person
appointed in this kind of situation an
identifiable conflict that made sense or
else doesn't it just become a
fabrication
well this now we're gonna shift from the
issue of writing the the memo or somehow
putting out a release later on and the
issue of the the actual direction to
McGann so the question on the direction
to McGann has a number of different
levels to it and first as a matter of
law I think the department's position
would be that the president can direct
the termination or the replacement of a
special counsel and as a matter of law
the obstruction statute does not reach
that conduct putting that aside the next
question would be even if it reached the
conduct could you here establish corrupt
intent beyond a reasonable doubt what
makes this case very interesting is that
when you take away the fact that there
were no underlying criminal conduct and
you take away the fact that there was no
inherently maligned
obstructive act that is the president
was carrying out his constitutional
duties the question is what is the
impact of taking away the underlying
crime and it's not as the report
suggests that one impact is well we have
to find some other reason why the
president would obstruct the
investigation but there's another impact
which is if the president is being
falsely accused which the evidence now
suggests that the accusations against
him were false if he and he knew they
were false and he felt that this
investigation was unfair propelled by
his political opponents and was and was
hampering his ability to govern that is
not a corrupt motive for replacing an
independent counsel so that's another
another reason that you know we would
say that the government would have
difficulty proving this beyond a
reasonable doubt senator Johnson and I
wrote you about text messages between
Peter Strock and Lisa page that appear
to show the FBI may have tried to use
counterintelligence briefings for the
Trump translation team as intelligence
gathering operations I hope you will
commit to answering the letter in
writing but also providing committees
the requested briefing that's my
question yes senator
have you already tasked any staff to
look into whether spying by the FBI and
other agencies on the Trump campaign was
properly predicated and can Congress
expect a formal report on your findings
yes I do have people in the department
helping me review the activities over
the summer of 2016 I suppose it depends
on what conclusions you come to but is
there any
and why Congress wouldn't be briefed on
on your conclusions it's a little early
for me to commit completely but I
envision some kind of reporting at the
end of this the Clinton campaign and the
Democratic National Committee hired
fusion GPS to do opposition research
against candidate Trump Fusion GPS then
hired Christopher Steele former British
intelligence officer to compile what we
all know is this Steele dossier that
reportedly used Russian government
sources for information the steel
dossier was central to the now debunked
collusion narrative well here's the
irony the malla report spent millions
investigating and found no collusion
between Trump campaign and Russia but
the Democrats paid for our document
created by a foreign national with
reported foreign government sources not
Trump but the Democrats that's the
definition of collusion despite the
central status of the steel dossier to
the collusion narrative the malla report
failed to analyze whether the dossier
was filled with disinformation to
mislead US intelligence agencies and the
FBI my question Muller spent over two
years thirty million dollars
investigating Russian interference in
the election in order for a full
accounting of Russia and interference
attempts shouldn't the Special Counsel
have considered on whether the steal
dossier was part of a Russian
disinformation and interference campaign
i I don't Special Counsel mother has put
out his report and I have not yet had
anyone go through the full scope of his
investigation to determine whether he
did address
look at all into those issues one of the
things I'm doing in my review is to try
to assemble all the existing information
out there about it not only from Hill
investigations and the OIG but also to
see what the Special Counsel looked into
so I really couldn't say what he
actually looked into but but you think
in other words if you had looked at all
that information right now you're
telling me you could have said yes or no
to my question if I had looked at it and
you're going to you're glad temp to find
some of this information that's
available
yes similarly should' the Special
Counsel have looked into the origins of
the FBI's investigation into alleged
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia the origins of that narrative yes
III I don't know if he viewed his
charter that broadly and I don't know
whether he did or not that's something
that I am reviewing and again will look
at whatever the Special Counsel has
developed on that yeah in volume 2 of
the report the Special Counsel declined
to make a traditional prosecutorial
decision instead the Special Counsel
laid out 200 or so pages relating to a
potential obstruction analysis and then
dumped that on your desk in your press
conference you said the u.s. a special
counsel whether he would have made a
charging decision or recommended charges
on obstruction but for the office of
legal counsels opinion on charging
sitting presidents and that the special
counsel made clear that was not the case
so mr. Barr is that an accurate
description your conversation was the
special console yes he he reiterated
several times and in a group meeting
that he was not saying that but for the
OLC opinion he would have found
obstruction if the special counsel found
facts sufficient to constitute
obstruction of justice would he have
stated that finding
if he had found that then I think he
would state it yes was it special
counsel Muller's responsibility to make
a charging recommendation I think the
Deputy Attorney General and I thought it
was but but but not just charging but to
to determine whether or not conduct was
criminal the president would would be
charged could not be charged as long as
he was in office do you agree with the
reasons that he offered for not making a
decision and volume two of his report
and why or why not I'm not really sure
of his reasoning I really could not
recapitulate his analysis which is one
of the reasons in my March 24th letter I
simply stated the fact that he did not
reach a conclusion didn't didn't try to
put words in his mouth I think that if
he felt that he shouldn't go down the
path of making a traditional prosecute
if decision then he shouldn't have
investigated that was the time to pull
up okay there have been a number of
leaks coming out of the Justice
Department FBI during high-profile
investigations the Inspector General
found that during the department's
investigation of Hillary Clinton for
mishandling highly classified
information there was a culture of
unauthorized media contacts during the
ricin of investigation the leaks
continued leaks undermine the ability of
investigators to investigate further
leaks to the papers while Congress has
questions to the department go
unanswered is unacceptable why what are
you doing to investigate unauthorized
media contacts by the department and FBI
officials during the Russian
investigation we have multiple criminal
leak investigations underway Thank You
Sara Lee
thank you John
I'm somewhat troubled by your your
testimony here and in the other body you
appeared before the House Appropriations
on April 9th
you asked about media reports and
betrayed the special counsels team is
frustrated the juror March 24th letter
didn't adequately portray the report's
findings when the congressman I believe
this congressman Chris asked if you knew
what those members of the special
counsels team were concerned about you
testified in response no I don't you
then said you really suspected they
would have preferred more information
was released with a letter now we know
contrary to what you said they pronate
then on March 27th Robert Mahler wrote
you expressing very specific concerns
that your March 24th letter
remember your testimony on April 9th but
your March 24th letter failed to capture
the heat to quote mr. Mulder the context
nature and substance close quarter of
his report and what I was really struck
me mr. Malla wrote that your letter
threatened to undermine a central
purpose for which the department
appointed the special counsel be sure
full public confidence in the outcome of
the investigation
why did you test by an April 9th that
you didn't know the concerns being
expressed by Mahler's team
what if fact you heard those concerns
directly from mr. baller
two weeks before well as I said I talked
directly to Bob Muller
about his letter to me and and
specifically asked them what exactly are
your concerns are you saying that the
March 24th letter was misleading or
inaccurate or what he indicated that it
was not he was not saying that and that
what he was concerned about my question
well I'm getting to the question which
is the
from crest was reports have emerged
recently press reports that members of
the special counsels team are Farrar
frustrated at some level with the
limited information included in your
March 24th letter in that they don't
adequately or accurately portray the
report's findings I don't know what
members he's talking about i died and i
and i certainly am not aware of any
challenge to the accuracy of the
findings my question was why did you say
you were not aware of concerns when
weeks before your testimony mr. molar
and expressed concerns - well that's a
fairly simple
well I answered a question and the
question was relating to unidentified
members who were expressing frustration
over the accuracy relating to findings I
don't know what that refers to at all
I talked directly to Bob Muller not
members of his team and even though I
did not know what was being referred to
and had and and Muller had never told me
that that that the expression of the
findings was inaccurate but I did then
volunteer that I thought they were
talking about the desire to have more
information put out but it wasn't my
purpose to put out more investigation
but his attorney conflict in that I'm
sorry could you just repeat that
Samantha Ford mr. :
we're told by transpersonal attorney it
be taken care of no you think it's fully
cooperating destructon a former aide to
tell the Attorney General to unbreak use
themselves shut down the investigation
and declare the President did nothing
wrong
I don't think well obviously since I
didn't find it it was obstruction I felt
that the evidence could not support is
that fully cooperating yep
he fully cooperated so I instructed a
former aide to tell the Attorney General
on recuse himself shut down the
investigation and declare the President
did nothing wrong that's fully
cooperating where's that in the report
that is on a volume 2 page 5 On June 19
point 17 the president dictated message
the message of the session is Republican
not did not receive refusal from the
rushed investigation the investigation
very unfair to the president the
president done nothing wrong right well
firstly asking sessions to Unruh cues
himself we do not think is a well I
don't know if that declares the
President did nothing wrong although the
president in terms of collusion did
nothing wrong isn't that correct
Hoosiers on a crime that's the
obstructing but is that fully
cooperating to say that well
I don't see any conflict between that
and fully cooperating with the
investigation the president of course
declared many times publicly in tweets
in the campaign rallies of the hall that
he would testify but he never did
testify right as far as I know I think
you know where they testified as far as
I know he didn't testify written answers
to be inadequate is that correct I think
he wanted additional but he never sought
it and the president never tell he never
he never pushed it the president never
testified does the fact that mr. Moyer
found the Trump campaign was receptive
to some of the offers of assistance from
Russia or the fact that the Trump
campaign never reported it in they
invested the FBI is that trouble you
what would they report to the FBI the
day were receptive to offers of
assistance from Russia what do you mean
by receptive I think the report says you
know obviously obviously they were they
were expecting to benefit from whatever
the Russian government those links in
some insisted the campaign was receptive
to the offer whereas others if we're not
well I have to unloose understand
exactly what that refers to
what what what communications that refer
to well you have the report I just gave
it a page from the report I know my time
is up and I'm making gentlemen nervous
no just very well done
Center corner general bar the chairman
has pointed out that after the Hillary
Clinton email investigation there were a
number and mr. commis press conference I
think it was July the 5th roughly 2016
there are a number of prominent
Democratic members of the Senate who
said that Comey should be should resign
or be fired I believe you said that
you've concluded as a matter of law that
the president is the head of the
executive branch of government has the
right to fire executive branch employees
was that correct that's right in this
case the president was relying at least
in part on a recommendation by the
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
arising out of fraud Rosenstein critique
of mr. commis conduct in holding that
press conference releasing derogatory
information about Secretary Clinton but
then announcing that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring charges against
her is that right that's right you
started your career I believe in the
intelligence community and then moved on
a course to the Department of Justice
and thank you for agreeing to serve
again as Attorney General and help
restore the department's reputation as
an impartial arbiter of the law and not
as a political arm of any administration
I think that's very very important that
you and director ray continue your
efforts in that regard and I'm grateful
to you for that
but I do believe that we need to ask the
question why didn't the Obama
administration do more as early as 2014
in investigating Russian efforts to
prepare to undermine and so dissension
in the 2016 election mr. Mueller's
report does document that the Russian
government through the intelligence
through their intelligence agencies and
their internet research or IRA I think
it's called
began as early as 2014 began their
efforts to do so and we know they met
with some success is it any surprise to
you based on your experience that the
Russians would try to do everything they
can to sow dissension in American
political life including in our
elections no not at all I mean I think
the the Internet
creates a lot more opportunities to have
a you know to have that kind of covert
effect on American body politic so it's
getting more and more dangerous but the
Russians have been at this for a long
time in various different ways but the
point you made about Bob Miller's
efforts on IRA it's one of the things
that struck me about the report I think
it's very impressive work that they did
and in moving quickly to get into the to
get into the IRA and also the the GRU
folks and I was thinking to myself if
that had been done in 2000 in the
beginning of 2016
we would have been a lot further along
for example we've heard a lot about the
Steele dossier mr. Steele of course as a
former British intelligence officer
hired by to do opposition research by
the Hillary Clinton campaign on on her
political adversaries including
President Trump or candidate Trump at
that time how do we know that the steel
dossier is not itself evidence of
Russian disinformation campaign knowing
what we know now that basically the
allegations made therein were secondhand
hearsay or unverified to my state with
confidence that the Russian that the
steel dossier was not part of the
Russian disinformation campaign no I
can't state that with confidence and and
that is one of the areas that I'm
reviewing I'm concerned about it and and
and I don't think it's entirely
speculative
well we know that from published reports
that the head of the CIA mr. Brennan the
went to President Obama and brought his
concerns about initial indications of
Russian involvement in the campaign as
early as the late of July late July 2016
and instead of doing more during the
Obama administration to look into that
and disrupt and deter Russian activities
that threatened the validity and
integrity of our campaign in 2016 it
appears to me that the Obama
administration Justice Department and
FBI decided to place their bets on
Hillary Clinton and focus their efforts
on investigating the Trump campaign but
as you have pointed out thanks to the
general thanks to the special counsel
we now have confidence that no Americans
colluded with the Russians in their
effort to undermine the American people
we now need to know and I'm glad to hear
what you are telling us about your
inquiries and your research and your
investigation we now need to know what
steps the Obama FBI Department of
Justice and intelligence community what
steps they took to undermine the
political process and put a thumb on the
scale in favor of one political
candidate over the other and that would
be before and after the 2016 election
what's the defensive briefing that in a
counterintelligence investigation well
you could have different kinds of
defensive briefings
if you learn that somebody is being
targeted by a hostile intelligence
service than one form of in defense of
briefing is to go and to alert that
person to the risks I think attorney
general Lynch has said it would it is
routine in counterintelligence
investigations would you agree with her
yes do you know whether a defensive
briefing ever given to the Trump
campaign by the FBI
based on their
counterintelligence investigation did
they ever tell the president before he
was January 2017 what the Russians were
trying to do and advised him to tell
people affiliated with this campaign to
be on on their guard and be vigilant
about Russian efforts to undermine
public confidence in the election my
understanding is that didn't happen that
would be annexed that failure to provide
a defensive briefing to the Trump
campaign that would be an extraordinary
or notable failure would you agree I
think under these circumstances one of
the things that I can't fathom why it
why it did not happen if you're
concerned about interference in the
election and you have you know
substantial people involved in the
campaign who were former US Attorney's
you had three former US attorneys there
in the campaign I don't understand why
the bureau would not have gone and and
given a defensive briefing
thank you sir Durbin thanks mr. chairman
thanks Jim Lebar I've been listening
carefully to my Republican colleagues on
the other side and the peers that they
are going to work together and
coordinate the so-called locker up
defense this is really not supposed to
be about the Muller investigation the
Russian involvement in the election the
Trump campaign and so forth it is really
about Hillary Clinton's emails finally
we get down to the bottom line Hillary
Clinton's emails and questions have to
be asked about Benghazi along the way
what about travelgate Warwick whitewater
there's a lot of material we should be
going through today according to their
response to this that is totally
unresponsive to the reality of what the
American people want to know they paid a
lot of money 25 million dollars for this
report and I respect mr. Muller and
believe he came up with a sound report
though I don't agree with all of it but
I find general Barr that some of the
things that you've engaged in really
leave me wondering what you believe your
role as Attorney General is when it
comes to something like this listen to
what since its put in the record let me
read it listen to what you received in a
letter on March 27th from Bob Muller
the summary letter of the department
sent to Congress and released to public
lately afternoon March 24th did not
fully capture the context nature and
substance of the offices work in
conclusions we communicated that concern
to the department on the morning of
March 25th there is now public confusion
about critical aspects of the results of
our investigation this threatens to
undermine a central purpose for which
the department appointed the special
counsel to assure full public confidence
in the outcome of the investigations I
cannot imagine that you received that
letter on March 24th and could not
answer congressman crisp directly when
he asked you whether there were concerns
about representations being made on
these findings by the people working for
Bob Muller you said no I don't know I
have to receive this letter what am I
missing
well as I explained to as I explained to
Senator Leahy I talk directly to Bob and
Bob told me that he did not have
objections to the accuracy attorneys
don't put things in writing unless
they're pretty serious about them
there's an old rule in politics a good
politician doesn't write a letter and
doesn't throw one away okay so I got to
ask you if he puts it in writing of his
concerns or your representations in the
March 24th you couldn't recall that when
congressman Chris asked you that
question a few days later no I'm saying
that this was the the the March 24th
letter stated that Bob Miller did not
reach a conclusion on obstruction and it
had the language in there about not
exonerating the president my view of
events was that there was a lot of
criticism of the special counsel for the
ensuing few days and on Thursday I got
this letter and when I talked to this
special counsel about the letter my
understanding was his concern was not
the accuracy of the statement of the
findings in my letter but that he wanted
more out there to provide additional
context to explain his reasoning on why
he didn't reach
a decision on obstruction I'll just say
this mr. boyeur
if you received a letter from bob miller
a few days after your March 24th letter
it was clear he had some general genuine
concerns about what you had said and
done to that point can we move to
another time his concerns was he wanted
more ad and I would analogize it to this
my job you know after after a
months-long trial if if I wanted to go
out and get out to the public what the
verdict was pending preparation of the
full transcript and I'm out there saying
here's the verdict and the prosecutor
comes up and taps me on the shoulder and
says well the verdict doesn't really
fully capture all my work I've got that
great you know cross-examination I did
or how about that third day of trial
where I did that this doesn't capture
everything my answer to that is I'm not
trying to capture everything I'm just
trying to state the verdict no you just
absolutely use the word summarize though
in your letter summarize the principled
conclusions or conclusions which most
people would view as a summary but let
me move to another topic if I can for a
minute the office of legal counsels
decision as to whether or not you can
prosecute a sitting president you had
some pretty strong feelings of that they
were reflected in your volunteered memo
to the Trump defense team your 19 page
memo did I discuss that you certainly
discussed whether or not a president
should cooperate with an investigation
you said at one point in summarizing the
findings of Muller that the White House
fully cooperated we know for a fact and
you've stated already the president
never submitted himself to what was
characterized as a vital interview an
actual sit-down interview under oath not
once and that his questions that there
were answered some 30 times his memory
failed him so to say the White House
fully cooperated that I think is a
generalist agendas conclusion on this
office of legal counsel I would refer
you to this volume 2 of the motor report
and on page 1 and he talks about the
whole issue of whether or not he was in
any way restricted and what he could
conclude because of the pen or the
outstanding office of legal counsel
opinion on the liability of a sitting
president you dismissed that in Europe
a statement and said we asked him two or
three times he said that had nothing to
do with it well how do you explain on
the first page of volume 2 that he says
I had a lot to do with it
it's the reason he couldn't reach a
binary conclusion on obstruction of
justice well no it was a Prudential
reason one of the backdrop factors that
he cited as influencing his Prudential
judgment that he should not reach a
decision which is different than citing
the OLC saying that but for the OLC
opinion I wouldn't die I'm just gonna
stand by what he has written and I asked
others to read it as well the last point
I want to make is about Don McGann if
you read the section here 100 pages 113
220 on Don begins experience the
president wanted him to state publicly
that the New York Times article was it
was untrue that he had not asked McGann
to fire the special counsel McGann
refused and there's some speculation as
to whether he risked being dismissed or
even resigning over this issue and for
you to suggest that this was some sort
of a kabuki dance with Rob Rosenstein I
think the president's intent here was
very clear he wanted this to end
he told Lester Holt going back to the
issue that was raised by the Chairman
earlier here the reason to get rid of
Comey is because the Russian
investigation I mean over and over again
this president was very explicit and
certainly is very expose Tory in his
style so I don't understand let me ask
you this conclusion my time is up do you
have any objections can you think of an
objection of why Don McGann shouldn't
come and testify before this committee
about his experience yes I mean I think
that he's he he's a close advisor to the
president every president ever exerted
executive privilege excuse me may have
already waived it now we haven't waived
the executive privilege well at this
point do you believe you're saying done
what about Bob mowers should he be
allowed to testify before this I've
already said publicly I have no
objection did and Don McGann should he
be allowed to testify I did that's a
call for the president to me well he's
private citizen at this point well I
assume he'd be testifying about
privileged matters
well I would hope that we could get to
the bottom of this with actual testimony
of witnesses after we take another
closer look to Hillary Clinton's emails
thank you we might do that certainly in
his classic dissent in Morrison V Olson
Justice Scalia remarked that nothing is
so politically effective as the ability
to charge that one's opponent and his
associates are not merely wrongheaded
naive and ineffective but in all
probability crooks and nothing so
effectively gives an appearance of
validity to such charges as a Justice
Department investigation that
observation has I think been borne out
time and time again over the past two
years time and time again the
president's political adversaries have
exploited the molar probe its mere
existence to spread baseless innuendo in
an effort to undermine the legitimacy of
the 2016 election and the effectiveness
of this administration for example on
January 25th 2019 Speaker Nancy Pelosi
asked what does Putin have on the
president politically personally or
financially mr. Attorney General is
there any evidence to suggest that
Vladimir Putin quote-unquote has
something on President Trump
none that I'm aware of on February 20th
2019 for Murr FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe said on national television to
the entire nation that he thinks it's
possible that Donald Trump is a Russian
agent mr. Attorney General is there any
evidence that you're aware of it
suggests even remotely the president
Trump is a Russian agent none that I'm
aware of
representative Erik's wawel has
repeatedly claimed that Donald Trump
quote acts on Russia's behalf Attorney
General Barr is there anything you're
aware of to back that up by way of
evidence the president acts on Russia's
behalf none that I'm aware of so
basically we've heard over and over
again on national
viii in committee hearings on the House
and Senate floor and in the media and
we've heard about the president's
alleged collusion with Russia but what
we have heard is as baseless as any
conspiracy theory that we've seen in
politics any that I can think of the
only difference here is that the
purveyors of this conspiracy were in
many cases prominent members of the
opposition party that's concerning now
from the beginning there were some
indications that the Russia
investigation was perhaps not always
conducted with the absolute impartiality
that the American people should expect
and have come to hope to find in
existence within the Department of
Justice especially given that the track
record of excellence that the US
Department of Justice has shown
according to the molar report itself the
investigation into the Trump campaign
began on July 31st 2016
after a foreign government contacted the
FBI about comments made by George
papadopolis
is that accurate or were there other
precipitating events that helped lead to
this that is that is the account that is
has been given in the past as to how it
got going well you've previously said
that you think it's possible that the
Federal Bureau of Investigation
improperly spied on the Trump campaign I
assume that's a reference to the FISA
warrant for Carter page is that what do
you have in mind are there other
circumstances that you've got in mind
there well one of the things I want to
look there are people many people seem
to assume that the only intelligence
collection that occurred was a single
confidential informant and a FISA
warrant I'd like to find out whether
that is in fact true it strikes me as a
fairly anemic effort if that was the
counterintelligence effort designed to
stop the threat as it's being
represented
it was Carter page under surveillance
during his time working for the Trump
campaign which was roughly January 2016
to September 2016 I don't know was any
other Trump campaign official under
surveillance during that time period
your note well these are the things that
I need to look at and I have to say that
as I've said before you know the extent
that there was any overreach I believe
it was some a few people in the in the
upper echelon of the bureau and and
perhaps the department but those people
are no longer there and I'm working
closely with Chris Rae who I think has
done a superb job at the bureau and
we're working together on trying to
reconstruct exactly what went down one
thing people should know is that the
bureau itself has been a little bit
handicapped in looking back because of
the pending Moeller investigation in the
OIG investigation as we know the FISA
warrant for Carter page was based
largely on the so-called steel dossier
and in particular on two specific facts
about pages trip to Moscow to deliver a
speech in July 2016 first according to
the warrant page had a secret meeting
with Igor session the president of
Rosneft is the molar report confirmed
that page met with session met with who
with with mister mister session with
Igor said Ike I can't I can't recall
that I don't remember that let me just
say that I want to stay away from
getting too deeply into the the FISA
issue because that's currently under
investigation by the OIG understood
second and more importantly the the
warrant also says that Paige met with
with Igor Vivian in order to discuss
what is referred to as comprar Matt
involving Hillary Clinton against
Hillary Clinton does the mole report
confirmed that Paige met with the deccan
I don't think so does it confirm that
Paige discussed comprar Matt
on Hillary Clinton with anyone not that
I recall though since the main
evidentiary support for the warrant has
been discussed by the molar report which
is sort of the gold standard of what
we're discussing here I'm I'm glad that
you're looking into it I'd encourage you
to look into why the FBI relied on this
false information and and I hope you'll
share the results the public obviously
has a right to know what happened here
the US Department of Justice the Federal
Bureau of Investigation have a long
history and a long history of success
that has been based on respect they
deserve to understand that there is not
so much power that's been concentrated
in that one agency that the outcome of
an investigation can depend on the whims
of who might be assigned to it they have
a right not to believe that a particular
investigation might be struck and paged
might not be tarm acting not but might
not be influenced by an improper
consideration politically or otherwise
Thank You mr. Attorney General
senator Whitehouse I'm told we're gonna
have two votes beginning 11:45 will do
senator Whitehouse and why don't we just
come back an hour later we'll break
break for an hour and do the votes and
have lunch
senator Whitehouse Thank You chairman
Attorney General you had a conversation
you
distance of this letter public the ones
that came out last night I think it
could have been yesterday but I'm not
sure when they contacted you to ask for
any comment they didn't contact me
contact a DOJ to ask for any comment I
can't actually remember how it came up
but someone mentioned it so you at some
point you knew that the Muller letter
was going to become public and that was
probably yesterday I think so okay now
when did you decide to make that letter
available to us in Congress this morning
would you concede that you had an
opportunity to make this letter public
on April 4th when representative Chris
asked you a very related question I
don't know what you mean by related
question it seems to me it'd be a very
different question I can't even follow
that down the road that mean boy that's
the masterful hair-splitting the letter
references enclosed documents and
enclosed materials right are those the
same things is what you called the
executive summaries that Muller provided
you with this letter yes yes it's all
the same document I'm sorry well you
talk about the executive summaries that
Muller provided you they are the
documents that were the enclosed
documents with that letter which we have
not been provided I think they were the
have been provided them there in the
report they're the summaries in the
report it's the language of the report
in the report there was nothing else
that he provided you then I think that's
what he provided okay if there is
anything else will you provide it to us
if it's different any form it's odd to
be given a letter without the
attachments to it when they attach I
think they're I think they were lettered
acted versions of the we get kind of
summaries that are embedded in the
report we get that just to be sure sure
great thank you you agree that none of
that material was either grand jury
see or presented risk to intelligence
sources and methods or would interfere
or compromise ongoing investigation or
affected were affected by executive
privilege
there were redactions made in the
executive summaries but as I said I
wasn't interested in putting out
summaries period well you know and right
this is another hair-splitting exercise
because Bob Muller who I think we all
agree is fairly credible actually
described your letter as a summary so
you can say it wasn't a summary but
Muller said it was a summary and I don't
think I wasn't I wasn't interested in
summarizing the whole report as I say I
was stating that the bottom line
conclusions of the report is that it's
intended to describe describe the report
meaning vol 1 don't you do a report or
pages and it's a 400-page report I don't
know why you're calving about whether it
has isomer because I stayed in the
letter that I'm stating to the principal
conclusions let me also say that you
know Bob Muller is the equivalent of a
US Attorney he was exercising the powers
of the Attorney General subject to the
supervision of the Attorney General he's
part of the Department of Justice his
work concluded when he sent his report
to the Attorney General at that point it
was my baby and I was making a decision
as to whether or not to make it public
and I effectively overrode the
regulations use discretion to to lean as
far forward as I could could to make
that public and was my decision how and
when to make it public knock Bob
Muller's with respect to the OLC opinion
that informed Bob Muller's decision as
he describes in the report do you agree
that that is merely an executive opinion
and that under our Constitution the
decision as to what the law is is made
by the judicial branch of the United
States government I'm sorry could you
with respect to the OLC opinion that
informed Muller's decision not to make a
recommendation on obstruction as he said
in his report do you concede that that
is an executive opinion ended under our
constitutional system what the law is
gets decided by
the judicial branch of government yes is
there any way for the OLC opinion to be
tested by the judicial branch of
government to see if it's correct or not
none that comes to mind and it could be
wrong could it not I guess
hypothetically insert oh there are legal
minds to disagree with it corrects me
there are many respected legal
commentators and professors and lawyers
who disagree with it correct it's very
hard to find lawyers that agree to
anything so the interesting thing to me
is that it goes on to say that because
of the oil sea opinion we have to give
the president an extra benefit of the
doubt because he is denied his day in
court
we could exonerate himself that seems
like fallacy to me because if you are
the president of the United States
you can either waive or readily override
the OLC opinion and say I'm ready to go
to trial I'm want to exonerate myself
let's go could you not how is this
relevant to my decisions it's relevant
because I assumed that there was no Elsi
opinion well we have a report in front
of us that says that this influenced the
outcome and in particular it says it
influenced the outcome because it
deprived the president of his ability to
have his day in court and my point to
you is that the president could easily
have his day in court by simply waiving
or overriding this OLC opinion that has
no judicial basis correct well I don't I
don't think that there was anything to
have a day in court on I think that the
government did not have a prosecutable
case but part well Muller obviously
didn't agree because he that's left that
up to you well well he said that he
could neither confirm nor deny that
there was a prosecutable case here he
left that to you and when he did he said
and you apparently have agreed that this
OLC opinion bears on it and it would be
unfair to the president to put him to
the burden of being indicted and not
having the
to be charged I don't want to
characterize how Bob's thought process
on this I'm not asking you to
characterize it it's in the it's in his
report he's put it right not sure what
he means with respect to the word can I
have a minute
I just want to nail down you used the
word spying mm-hmm about authorized DOJ
investigative activities are you talking
about my testimony we got the House
Appropriations yes in the entirety of
your previous career in the Department
of Justice including as Attorney General
have you ever referred to authorized
Department investigative activities
officially or publicly as spying I'm not
asking for private conversation I'm not
going to have juror the use of the word
spying I think you know my first job was
in CIA and I don't think the word spying
has any pejorative connotation at all to
meet us maybe the question is always
whether or not it's authorized and
adequately predicated spying
I think spying is a good English word
that in fact doesn't have synonyms
because it is the broadest word
incorporating really all forms of covert
intelligence collection so I'm not going
to back off the word spying except I
will say when did you adjust thing any
pejorative and I use it frequently when
has you media when did you decide to use
it was it off-the-cuff in the hearing
that day or did you go into that hearing
intently new is the worry there's
actually off the cuff to tell you the
truth and when when a senator the the
senator I mean the congressman probably
from Schatz from Hawaii was here so you
know whoever it was go ahead yeah when
when he challenged me and said you want
to change your language I was actually
thinking like what's the issue I don't
consider it a pejorative but if and
irreverently frankly we went back and
looked at press usage and up until all
the the for outrage a couple of weeks
ago it's commonly used in the press to
refer to authorized activities such as
refer it is Michael Hartman what it is
not commonly used by the department my
time is commonly used by me
thank you very much we'll come back at
ten to one thank you